las gráficas de las funciones semi
coseno se ven con bastante onda si las
juntamos parecen olas del mar y siempre
tocan el eje x de manera regular es
decir que repite en un ciclo una y otra
vez viendo cada segmento podemos notar
el patrón cada una de estas repeticiones
se llama periodo el periodo inicia en
cualquier punto y termina en donde el
patrón volvería a repetirse como si le
dieras una vuelta a la gráfica esto nos
sirve para determinar la frecuencia de
un evento es decir la cantidad de ciclos
periodos o repeticiones que hay entre el
tiempo en que ocurren una gráfica de
como brincamos la cuerda sería senoidal
porque ilustra movimientos repetitivos
constantes al dar cierto número de
brincos en determinado tiempo se generan
estas ondas en este caso la gráfica
registra el número de brincos que hay
cada cinco segundos por lo que cada que
cumplimos un periodo tendremos un brinco
2 3 y 4 damos cuatro brincos en cinco
segundos si la gráfica avanzará otros
cinco segundos
tendríamos otros cuatro brincos entonces
sustituimos en nuestra fórmula de
frecuencia estos valores y obtenemos que
brincamos a una frecuencia de cuatro
quintos de hertz así de sencillo
relacionar los periodos de una gráfica
cíclica para obtener la frecuencia de
repetición